we all have a spatial Dimension that
determines our relationship to each
other and to our surroundings when these
dimensions are disrupted it can have
really serious psychological impacts and
he calls this idea proxemics in his book
The Hidden Dimension he talks about a
crowding experiment where they took a
group of 48 rats they were given
everything they needed except for
personal space there was a quick
population boom followed by such a
severe psychological and behavioral
disruption that it eventually led to
their Extinction he called these
behavioral sinks it distorted their
behavior and a lot of the rats had
tumors and enlarged kidneys all of which
are signs of extreme stress the crowding
led to a pathological behavior in the
rats although humans have developed the
level of cognitive sophistication that
makes us think before we act the limbic
system is still one of the oldest parts
of the brain and it has a direct
connection to the brain stem we still
have an instinctive spatial Dimension
that influences how we interact in
different environments